here with reaction we have texas senator
ted cruz is with us ted i saw you you're
kind of looking around a little bit you
looked a little bored to me
but
it seems like if i were to sum this up
ignore all the failure give out a lot of
bumper stickers slogans platitudes
um and not address what's actually
happening in the world more specifically
the one sanction that would work as it
relates to russian ukraine and that of
course would be stopping the importation
and exportation of any energy by
vladimir putin
sean i think that's exactly right you
know tonight was the tenth state of the
union that i've been on the floor of the
house of representatives to hear from
the third different president and
this was the most out of the touch state
of the union speech that i have ever
heard
biden went through a litany of
acknowledging some of the problems we
face in this country
but utterly denying any responsibility
any culpability for it so he
acknowledged galloping inflation but
didn't say a word about the trillions in
spending and trillions of debt he ran
through that caused that inflation he
acknowledged gas prices are skyrocketing
but didn't say a word about the war on
domestic energy production that his
administration led he acknowledged the
need to secure our southern border but
didn't say a word
about the failure of his administration
to enforce the laws leading to the
highest rate of illegal immigration in
61 years
on ukraine he acknowledged russia's
invasion but didn't say a word about the
disastrous weakness from his
administration the catastrophic
withdrawal from afghanistan or his
decision to wave sanctions on russia on
putin's nordstrom 2 pipeline which is
what directly led to this invasion on
every issue
he was like sergeant schultz from
hogan's heroes i see nothing i hear
nothing with him that may be right
but but he denied
any and all culpability and i'll tell
you four words that i didn't hear at all
tonight i didn't hear crime he didn't
acknowledge the crime rate that that is
soaring across this country the murder
rate that is soaring across this country
because of the democrats push to abolish
the police he didn't say the word china
even once it was stunning that china is
the greatest geopolitical threat facing
the united states and somehow it didn't
make it into the speech he didn't say
afghanistan he didn't even acknowledge
the disgraceful surrender and retreat
that he led and he didn't say israel
that was really striking in a state of
the union i think it was really a
disappointing speech let me ask you why
do you think he didn't mention
afghanistan and china for example
i agree with your assessment completely
and frankly we're watching the
territorial ambitions of putin unfold
worldwide
i would expect that china
probably in pretty short order is going
to reunify their words with taiwan and
basically take over that country and i
don't think joe biden or any country in
the world is going to lift a finger to
stop china
no no that's exactly right the russian
invasion of ukraine was caused by two
things number one last year biden's
disastrous withdrawal from afghanistan
his surrender to the taliban his his
leaving americans behind his abandoning
bagram airfield releasing terrorists
which led to the murder of 13 service
men and women and what happened sean is
enemies of america across the world
enemies like russia like china like
north korea and iran they all looked to
washington
and they took the measure of the man in
the oval office and unfortunately they
concluded that he was weak and feckless
and ineffective and i said at the time
the chances of a russian invasion of
ukraine have just increased tenfold and
as you just referenced the chances of a
chinese invasion of taiwan have
increased tenfold that when the american
president is weak and when he's
perceived as weak our enemies are
emboldened in the worlds more dangerous
now there's a lot we could be doing on
ukraine right now and you made reference
in your opening monologue to the most
important step we could do right now
which is boycotting russian energy
boycotting russian oil and gas you know
biden put sanctions in but remarkably he
put exceptions for energy putin gets the
bulk of his funds from selling oil and
gas and biden accepted that just like he
did on the nordstream 2 pipeline we need
to make the nordstrom 2 sanctions let's
set it permanently
russian oil and gas
gotta emphasize that joe biden
artificially reduced the world supply
and as a result
he pushed our allies nato allies
european allies right into the arms of
putin now if you look at what's going on
and what's been happening all day you've
got a 40-mile convoy of russian military
vehicles uh that are snaking towards
kiev
then of course from belarus they'll head
south right to kiev and it seems like a
massive military undertaking is about to
take place and i would imagine that
there's going to be a lot of dead people
as a result of this
next stage of this invasion your
thoughts
so we're seeing extraordinary heroism
from the ukrainian people and they're
standing and defending their homes we
need to be providing them
with with lethal military equipment more
stingers more javelins they are fighting
the russian army putin is shocked at how
ferociously they're defending their
homeland the biden administration last
year in both april and december halted
the transfer of military equipment to
ukraine because they wanted to appease
putin that was a mistake but i'll tell
you this afternoon i sat down with the
former ceo of ukraine's largest natural
gas company and he was talking about how
putin
is counting on the fact that europe is
addicted to his gas and to his oil and
putin believes no matter what he does
europe needs that natural gas and oil we
need to impose a boycott on russian oil
and gas and replace it replace it with
american production after this speech i
pulled the u.s secretary of state tony
blinken aside and i said listen we have
an opportunity texas can stand up and
produce the natural gas we can produce
the oil but the biden administration has
got to clear the export of liquid
natural gas and if we fill european
demand
nothing will weaken putin more than
taking away his revenue and and one of
the things that's really striking if the
european refineries are looking for
another source of oil and and gas
they're not going to be able to purchase
that just on the spot market the
producers are going to ask for long-term
contracts and if the european refineries
are signing long-term contracts with
american producers or other producers
around the world
that will both terrify putin and weak
him weak at him fundamentally with the
oligarchs
and and with the security infrastructure
there that is actually fighting to win
but i'll tell you sean my concern is i
hear from biden's national security team
they don't believe in winning this war
they are almost resigned to putin
conquering ukraine and and i think if we
stand and use the economic might of
america if we envision victory you know
reagan said very powerfully during the
cold war what's your objective we win
they lose that should be our objective
here and we can do it with economic
might with a boycott of russian oil and
gas and with providing military
equipment to ukraine so they can defend
their nation not u.s soldiers but
ukrainians defending their own homeland
senator i had the same exact reaction
and that is that they basically are
conceding the entire country of ukraine
and ukraine will fall without the
javelins uh without the stinger missiles
hopefully they'll get enough and then
the question is going to be okay will
nato be a paper tiger or will they stand
up and fight if it's estonia or
lithuania or
latvia that's a question i can't answer
tonight and the one sanction that would
have worked is to put an end to
dependence on all things energy from
russia
and that's the one thing they didn't do
that would have been the most effective
sanction well said senator ted cruz of
texas thank you